leur mail elle avait fait des
télévisions là effet l'émission
quotidien démission c'est tabou juste
après the wrist mais ça fait deux ans
donc elle ne s'est pas exprimé c'est
vrai qu'on se demandait tous ceux
qu'elle devenait mesnel déjà pourquoi
avoir accepté l'invitation de balances
ton post ce qu'on est en direct
et c'est vrai que j'avoue j'ai été un de
ceux qui qui n'a pas été tendre avec
vous concernant vos tweets de l'époque
voilà pourquoi avoir accepté alors
honnêtement si j'avais accepté c'est pas
pour te voir cyril ceni pour les
chroniqueurs ni pour tout ça c'est juste
parce que je pense qu'à un moment donné
j'ai le droit de parler en mon nom sans
qui est des gens qui parlent à ma place
d'accord mais pourquoi cette émission
parce que on en direct parce que voilà
que tu voulais exprimer sur cette
émission
bah écoute cette émission une autre mais
je pense qu'aujourd'hui j'ai plus de
force mentale pour pouvoir affronter les
premiers qui m'ont descendu d'accord et
je pense que aujourd'hui
j'ai tourné la page depuis un moment et
j'ai envie que les gens sachent et toi
aussi et puis surtout pour ma paix
intérieure de de dire qui je suis et
qu'on sache qui je suis alors de tout ce
qu'il dit
on vous a connu d'entre eux sont 2018
vous aviez repris la chanson de leonard
cohen hallelujah tous les coachs s'était
retourné rappelez vous
[Musique]
allez nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
métairie
destot est de lima
tiens
[Musique]
alors ce soir là c'est la consécration
pour vous mais neil tous les coachs se
retourne tout on ne parle que de vous et
de votre voix exceptionnelle là ce soir
là vous vous dites je vis un rêve j'ai
toujours aimé la musique depuis je suis
petit et au début quand on m'a proposé
de faire l'émission où j'étais c'était
pour moi c'était un rêve artistique et
je cherchais pas impressionner la
galerie c'était mon but premier c'était
vraiment de partager ce qui met plus
cher et mon moyen d'expression
parce que pour moi la musique c'est une
thérapie c'est je trouve que les
artistes on est des médecins du cac donc
après la diffusion ce que je vois il
s'est enregistré donc le soir de la
diffusion
vous êtes dans un rêve ouais mais pour
moi c'est clairement un rêve
voilà et dès le lendemain ce rêve va
devenir un cauchemar puisque des postes
facebook et twitter que vous avez écrit
sont ressortis on va pas les citer ce
soir et vous êtes devenu un sujet de
débat donc là le soir de diffusion vous
êtes dans un rêve
vous faites ce que vous aimez le plus au
monde c'est à dire chanter vous êtes
reconnu pour vos talents de chanteuse et
vos talents artistiques et le lendemain
c'est vrai que vous faites tellement le
buzz que beaucoup de personnes vont
chercher des tweets ou des post facebook
que ça que vous avez pu faire les
ressorts tu es là vous êtes au centre du
débat
est-ce que vous avez compris pourquoi
vous faisiez débat à ce moment là en
fait aujourd'hui je m'en fous ne
m'intéresse pas de savoir pourquoi qui
commande parce que au final il ya eu
tellement de choses qui se sont dites
que ce qui m'intéresse c'est pas de
savoir pourquoi on a dit telle chose qui
m'intéresse c'est de montrer qui je suis
alors tout ce que j'ai a présenté vous
avez décidé après très vite de présenter
vos excuses
vous avez dit ces messages étaient
l'expression d'une peur que je
partageais seulement cette époque avec
mes amis sur ce réseau
je regrette profondément ces messages
deux ans après j'ai mûri et je mesure le
manque de réflexion de ces messages je
comprends que ces messages chocs et je
m'en excuse
vous vous regrettez donc toujours ces
messages aujourd'hui
forcément et quelques jours après la
polémique qui ne cesse d'enfler vous
expliquez que vous quittez the voice
regardez cette vidéo en tant qu artiste
chanteuse
j'ai participé à deux voice avec
l'intention de rassembler pas de diviser
d'ouvrir les esprits pas de lézat sont
gris je vis très difficilement les
tensions survenues ces derniers jours
j'ai donc pris aujourd'hui la décision
de quitter cette aventure je continuerai
de chanter pour louer ce sentiment
qu'ils réparent les fractures et
rapproche les gens malgré leurs
différences merci à ceux qui pardonnent
les maladresses je vous aime c'est votre
décision
c'était votre décision et non pas celle
de tf1 non madame ans qu'il joue en ma
place quand ça parle de toi partout tout
le temps et qu'on dit des bêtises pas
possible il n'y avait pas que des
bêtises qu'il y avait il y avait les
tweets une dernière les postes facebook
quoi qu'il en soit ils ont été écrits
après vous avez vous vous êtes excusés
nous par exemple pour donner l'exemple
de touche pas à mon poste on parlait de
vous on vous a toujours défendu
concernant la polémique qui lie à vue
concernant votre ruban en revanche c'est
vrai que sur les tweets concernant vos
tweets on vous a toujours voilà enfoncé
et mine de rien voilà après vous êtes
excusés mais c'est vrai que sur le ruban
on n'a jamais compris la polémique
qu'avait eus je sais pas quoi la
question elle est de savoir que je suis
arrivé je me présente je suis une jeune
fille j'aime la musique je veux chanter
basta et ensuite il ya des problèmes on
veut pas que je chante on veut pas que
je continue de vous comprenez que tout
non mais la décision de partir parce que
pour ma santé psychologique j'ai pris le
chou partir et vous la dire les mélèzes
les choses à vous comprenez mesnel que
va-t-on revenir dessus vous vous
comprenez mesnel que vos publications
que ce soit sur twitter ou sur facebook
ait pu choquer les gens et forcément
quand on est exposé médiatiquement comme
vous l'avez été parce que vous avez fait
un énorme buzz grâce à votre talon sur
the voice vous comprenez que les gens
qui puissent être choqués et qui peut se
demander des explications super venu
j'ai pas venu pour rendre d'accord voilà
donc oui mais donc vous comprenez
qu'aujourd'hui forcément oui on
c'est normal qu'ils aient eu une
polémique alors vous dites que c'est
votre décision pas celle de tf1 parce
que vous avez craqué sous la pression de
tous tous ces gens qui parlent de vous
j'en pouvais plus alors il ya peu que
vos tweets donc ils ont fait parler
aussi le fait que vous portez un ruban
depuis vous êtes cité dès qu'il ya une
affaire autour du voile ou de l'islam en
france vous êtes cité bizarrement vous
êtes devenu voilà c'est vrai exactement
donc comment le vivez-vous ça être un
symbole devenir un flambeau c'est pas ce
pourquoi je cherche à exister
je veux juste être moi même présenté ce
que je sais faire et c'est tout et que
si on aime on suit si on n'aime pas on
prend pas vous avez quitté la france à
la suite de toutes ces polémiques où je
suis parti poursuit que c'était le seul
moyen voyage pour moi c'est mon
échappatoire
j'aime énormément voyagé ça m'inspire
dans ma création artistique donc ouais
je voyage échoué ce trait soit vous avez
quel âge aujourd'hui mais des 24 dont
xavier 22 ans à l'époque des voix la 2cv
et 20 ans à l'époque des publications
voilà c'est ce que vous aviez dit est-ce
que quitter la france était le seul
moyen de vivre sereinement bronze
sereinement c'est pas une question de
pays je pense c'est une question de paix
intérieure et j'ai cherché cherché à
apaiser par ce qui était à ma portée de
main et en l'occurrence à l'époque j'ai
eu cette opportunité de partir de france
pour un petit moment et ça me sortait
une certaine sérénité
vous avez souffert de tout ce qui s'est
passé autour de vous savez j'avais
regretté un moment d'avoir fait the
voice non jamais jamais qu'est-ce que
vous avez regretté alors je regretterais
je regrette rien je prends les choses
comme elles viennent et j'apprends à
vivre avec
alors il ya quelques jours vous avez
posté des photos de vous sans votre tu
rebond des photos massivement commentée
par la presse
c'est fou le buzz que vous pouvez faire
parce que c'est vrai que deux ans après
partout on a parlé de vous on a dit
voilà là elle a enlevé son turban on
c'est vrai que alors qu'est ce que vous
pensez de ces commentaires je pense que
de toute façon quoi qu'on fasse dans la
vie il y aura toujours des personnes
pour pour être en accord ou en désaccord
pour savoir
soi même ce qu'on doit faire en
l'occurrence j'ai porté un turban sur ma
tête je faisais le choix de couvrir mes
cheveux donc c'est mon choix et
aujourd'hui je ne pouvais plus mes
cheveux tout le temps pourquoi parce que
c'est mon choix pro vous avez changé
d'avis parce que c'est moins chemin
spirituel
d'accord vous avez 17 ma vie elle tourne
pas qu'autour de la musique chez d
autres choses c'est à dire que quand je
me lève le matin tous mes choix de vie
ne sont pas systématiquement défini par
ma carrière mais qu'est-ce qui a fait
que ça a changé parce que mine de rien
vous étiez présenté à the voice oui avec
votre tour bons mais j'étais une
personne avec certaines convictions et
puis j'étais comme cela à c'est à ce
moment là
aujourd'hui j'ai évolué je change je
deviens quelqu'un des différents fils
surcadencé sur son soutien à une
personne c'est sûr qu'au 6 à votre âge
on peut on peut changer on peut je pense
que c'est logique puis on passe tous par
un cheminement qui soit à spirituel ou
vendent en termes de développement
personnel et à partir de là je pense
avoir le droit quand même de décider de
changer d' adapter ma vie selon cette
bien dans votre peau aujourd'hui vous
êtes bien beaucoup mieux plus apaisé
parce que j'apprends en fait tu as à
dire aux gens voilà je suis comme ça et
j'ai pas me travestir et j'ai pas à
plaire à tout le monde parce que je sais
que ce que j'offre c'est sincère et
authentique
je sais qu'avec mon coeur est avec ce
qui m'anime du plus profond
vous avez pris le temps de réfléchir à
tout ce qui s'était passé pendant ces
deux ans bastide et vous avez réfléchi
vous êtes dit voilà c'est vrai que
j'étais dans un tourbillon médiatique
tu as tu veux prendre un petit peu de
recul en deux ans 1 pendant deux ans
j'ai fait beaucoup de choses j'ai
principalement j'ai beaucoup composé de
chansons
parce que je suis pas juste chanteuse je
compose mes titres et j'ai aussi
beaucoup fait de sport de méditation
tout ce qui pouvait en fait tu m'as
apporté de la sérénité et à côté de ça
j'ai jamais vraiment prêté attention
méchanceté ou bien aux critiques faciles
comme la pour le turban c'est la
critique facile je suis roulé côte et
non mais ça faut pas s'arrêter à ça ça
vraiment sa cdc des critiques qui sont
pas constructives et celle ci vraiment
mais moi j'étais étonné que y est c'est
fait autant d'articles que vous ayez
enlevé entre rebond sur moi en fait
faites ce que vous voulez depuis la fin
de the voice il ya plein de gens qui me
dit comment vous parvenez à vivre de
votre métier de chanteuse
je fais est saine d'accord des
collaborations tous qu'une artiste
puisse faire peut faire pour un pour
exister pour vivre de sa passion
alors quels sont vos projets musicaux la
désormais maintenant vous savez en ce
moment je travaille sur le prochain
album et qui du coup c'est un album qui
est très très inspiré de ces deux
dernières années mais c'est plus un
album de renouveau ça visa en fait je
veux vraiment parler à travers ma
musique j'aime et j'aimerais être un
modèle de résilience en modèle de
d'apprendre à lâcher prise et d'aller de
continuer à faire ce qu'on aime quand
bien même autour de soi il ya des
tempêtes parce que j'avais pensé à tout
arrêter en mouvement bah oui c'est ça en
fait avec tout ce qui m'arrivait j'avais
deux options soit arrêté solution de
facilité quand on est dans le confort ou
bien me dire mais ce que j'aime
énormément ce que j'aime le plus je
laisserai personne me détruire et
aujourd'hui être chanteuse être artiste
c'est pas une chose simple c'est pas une
vie confortable mais c'est une vie qu'on
veut et qu'on choisit alors aujourd'hui
je vous avez un message à faire passer
aux médias français
aujourd'hui si votre retour médiatique
et c'est vrai que ya plein de gens qui
dit oui c'est vrai que c'est le retour
médiatique de médailles mais c'est vrai
qu'on a parlé de vous on a si c'est
pareil vous pendant deux ans comme je
voulais dit même si vous étiez à
l'étranger c'est incroyable qu'est ce
que vous auriez à leur dire bonjour
alors dire que si jamais ça leur rang
ça reste sens de parler de ma musique
welcome sinon si c'est pour une énième
fois mme m'assimiler à des problèmes
sociaux politiques non merci parce que
je suis encore une fois je le répéterai
jamais assez artistes donc aujourd'hui
c'est la dernière fois que vous parliez
d'autre chose que de votre musique vous
les clôtures et voilà cet épisode ce
soir
oui mais de toute façon ça fait bien
longtemps que les clôtures et mais
aujourd'hui voilà médiatiquement je ne
donne pas la porte ouverte aux médias de
venir encore une forme parler de ce qui
s'est passé il ya deux ans
donc la prochaine fois que vous serez
sur un plateau de télé les règles soient
internes album voilà c'est juste parler
d'autres albums mais on parle plus du
passé non d'accord on ne vient pas
l'intérêt pour le public voilà après
maintenant voilà vous est expliqué ce
soir
voilà mais c'est vrai que les gens ont
besoin de savoir si un artiste c'est
aussi une histoire et c'est vrai que
vous un art si c'est une histoire je
suis d'accord c'est une histoire mais
une vraie une vraie histoire qu'on
raconte pas des bêtises
et puis surtout mon histoire c'est une
histoire cuisine pas mal subi c'est à
dire qu' il y avait beaucoup de choses
où s'étaient malgré moi quand je suis
partie de l'émission c'était malgré moi
je pleurais je pleurais et puis beaucoup
de témoins qui m'ont vu mais c'était
horrible pour moi c'est comme abandonné
un petit bébé je voulais pas partir je
savais que j'allais au live je savais
que j'allais aller super loin et me dire
j'abandonne de mon plein gré mais c'est
une souffrance pour main donc je vous
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous vous avouer
avoir fait des erreurs mais comme tout
le monde j'ai fait des erreurs
donc vous avez payé ses erreurs
aujourd'hui il de rien on quitte le sens
pas en fait je pense pas avoir payé des
erreurs parce qu'en soit tout le monde
fait des erreurs mais sa géométrie
variable ont fait payer ce qu'on veut
faire payer pour quoi vous pensez vous
avez été vous avez un traitement quêter
qui était moins favorable que pour
d'autres personnes
on sait que si ça avait été quelqu'un
d'autre pensais qu'il y aurait moins de
polémiques autour de votre c'est parce
que simplement je suis musulmane et qui
porte un turban
c'était pensez vraiment ces rencontres
est clairement vous pensez vraiment que
les chroniqueurs par exemple de touche
pas à mon poste vous sont tombés dessus
à cause de ça alors vous vous trompez
après ça c'est des cons je lui dis dur
là mais je cède clairement que
je vous dis mais elles pourront revenir
là dessus comme ça on va clôturer le
débat sur votre turban et sur votre rue
ben on a été au contraire dans toutes
les émissions et dans toutes les
émissions dans lesquelles j'ai été
on s'est vraiment insurgé contre toutes
les formes de voile à de critiques qu'il
ya eu autour de votre cru bon c'était
pas une classe soir sa nouvelle jolie
le seul truc sur lequel on a été
intransigeant c'est sur vos tweets qui
je le dis encore aujourd'hui en
clôturant le débat chaud pas qu'on
revienne là-dessus ce que vous n'êtes
pas venu pour ça je vous le dis sur les
tweets qui était inadmissible
vous avez écrit des tweets qui était
inadmissible vous le regrettez
aujourd'hui on fait tous des erreurs
alors aujourd'hui on peut dire oui vous
avouez vous avez à vous et vos erreurs
ont maintenant vous êtes une artiste et
vous avez envie d'être juste une artiste
et être reconnu comme une artiste mais
je vous dis sur le ruban le turban on a
été le premier à vous défendre et on
vous a défendu contre vraiment vents et
marées compte sur les sur les tweets qui
était inadmissible
impossible de vous défendre ouais c'est
tout après vous avez dit que vous aviez
regretté les tweets que vous avez publié
aujourd'hui vous nous avez demandé de
palais m on y mettra pas mais juste
comprenez que c'est pas là je pense
qu'il ya pas eu deux poids deux mesures
sur le tueur mans et sur le sur le
turban que vous portiez dans un abri
c'était inadmissible et critiques que
vous avez subie sur les réseaux sociaux
et tous les abrutis qui ont écrit sur
vous concernant votre turban ça
franchement voilà le traité d'abruti
aujourd'hui et ils ont rien compris
parce qu'on juge d'artistes sur les
tweets ils ont été inadmissibles et
forcément on était obligé de revenir
dessus
parce que forcément quand on est quand
on est mais quand on est médiatiquement
très exposé et vous étiez la star de
cette saison de the voice forcément il
ya des gens qui cherchent et voilà
qu'ils essaient de trouver des choses
qui peuvent qui peut vous compromettre
peut-être que vous auriez dû dire juste
avant j'ai écrit des tweets que je
regrette j'étais jeune j'avais 19 ou 20
ans voilà je disais n'importe quoi
j'étais peut-être influencé mais
aujourd'hui deux ans après eh ben je
peux vous dire j'ai revu ma façon de
penser et je pense pas du tout ce que
j'avais écrit il ya deux ou trois ans
voilà c'est tout mais au nom nocturne
n'avait rien contre mon camp c'est que
maintenant mais à l'egypte par les
détenus ce que vous avez à dire non mais
vous étiez en train de me dire quelque
chose était en train de dieu oui si je
peux dire un mot c'est
la question s'était voulait poser une
question oui exactement
et moi ma question c'est tjrs que
c'était pas un peu trop gros quand même
tout ça trop gros noms c'est à dire tout
ce qui touche je vous dis je vous dis là
d'ailleurs que ça a pris je suis pas
d'accord avec vous je vais vous dire
pourquoi vous étiez sur la première
chaîne européenne vous étiez sur tf1
donc vu par des milliers et des milliers
de personnes the voice aujourd'hui c'est
une des émissions qui le plus regardé
par les jeunes
vous allez devenir un symbole et un
exemple pour de nombreux jeunes qui vous
regarde et on pouvait pas laisser passer
dans une émission médias comme des pmp
quelqu'un qui a fait des tweets incitons
à la haine
giuly 6 bat si pour moi si je vous dis à
ma femme est dépeinte de ça c'est bon
alors voir débattent de ça donc voilà
donc vous pouvez pas le faire parce que
vous êtes un exemple il était un exemple
pour les jeunes pour la jeunesse et vous
étiez sur tf1 la première chaîne
française
aujourd'hui on était obligé d'en parler
et si vous aviez dit tout de suite
écoutez je regrette c'est vrai j'étais
jeune on oublie et vraiment je regrette
ce que j'ai dit j'ai pu dire des
conneries et christine oui c'est ce que
vous avez dit exactement doc après on
l'a bien dit aujourd'hui moi je pense
que c'est très bien que vous exprimiez
aujourd'hui et que vous avez comme j'ai
dit entre guillemets série de purges et
votre peine parce que c'est rêver
d'aller passer deux ans voilà on en
dessous des radars et vous avez un
talent immense élan on arrive ça on l'a
toujours toujours toujours dit dans mes
émissions
joli et voilà aujourd'hui j'ai envie de
m'adresser à l'artiste à la chanteuse
que vous êtes et qu'est ce que vous
attendez aujourd'hui vous voulez juste
qu on vous considère comme enel la
chanteuse l'artiste et qu'on arrête de
vous parler de tout ce qui a eu avant
voilà alors je sais que votre nouveau
single s'appelle ça va pourquoi avoir
choisi ça va parce que ça va c'est un
titre qui parle de deux prétendants
allait bien quand tout va mal de ne
porter un masque ce qu'on fait c'est
souvent société et est aujourd'hui j'ai
envie de de déconstruire ce faux
semblant et en disant que quand ça va
vendre un bien le droit deux tiers et on
est obligé de toujours faire bonne
figure vous avez essayé de faire bonne
figure vous de nombreux soit dire ça va
mais alors que ça n'allait pas du tout
plein de cochonneries plusieurs femmes
et aujourd'hui ça va aujourd'hui ça va
beaucoup beaucoup ça va beaucoup mieux à
écouter
vous allez nous chanter votre nouveau
single en exclusivité en live dans
balances ton post je suis très heureux
de l'écouté j'ai hâte de l'écouter comme
tous les téléspectateurs et je vous le
dis je vous souhaite une belle carrière
de chanteuse alors vous allez vous vous
êtes vous même au piano c'est ça oui le
jeu au piano et chaque compagnie aussi
avec mon guitariste et bien très bien
c'est ça va s'aimer d'elle c'est
vraiment une exclu ppp merci mille elle
vous écoute mais dell en live à les
rejoindre la scène
merci c'est la première fois que mais
elle va chanter ce titre en live ça va
et c'est vrai que sélectionné on est en
direct
il est minuit set avant de laisser
mesnel chanter je voudrais vous dire
merci à vous d'avoir été là les
éditorialistes merci merci à vous tous
on écoute mais neil et on se quitte
juste après bonne nuit à vous tous et
bien sûr on se retrouvera lundi pour
touche pas à mon poste est tout de suite
c'est mesnel avec ça va merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
un petit peu laissé le soe règle assez
souvent
[Musique]
je ne mens
ils disent que ça va passer
tout finit par s'effacer
lentement
[Musique]
/
mais tout ce que je
ou pas
et si tu
[Musique]
ce montant
non
suivant
passé
ça va
[Musique]
je passe mon temps
et
ça va faut pas que ça se sache tout ce
que j'ai construit je ferai une fusion
je leur dois
bien ça
[Musique]
multiplier les masques de maquiller les
phrases que derrière mais effectivement
102 x
tout comme toi
mais tout ce que je
dit pas tout
mais si tu
[Musique]
à
je
n'est ce pas
semblant tu vas
[Musique]
l'obligation de faire diversion ça ira
et touché le fond faire bonne impression
je ne peux pas
et l'obligation de faire diversion et
toucher font faire bonne impression
je ne veux pas
[Musique]
j'vais ce montant fait semblant tu vois
je passe mon temps à dire ça alors
[Musique]
sarah
[Musique]
mais elle